disturbing human experiments aren't
something the average person thinks
about too much
while in real life human experiments
tend to be creepy in anime they're
creepier and painful
but unlike in real life in anime the lab
rats get special abilities aka
superpowers so today's video is about
characters that escape human
experimenting
while using their special abilities
before we start be sure to like and
subscribe
became the lovable teacher who looks
like a retired hen tentacle monster
he was the best assassin known as the
reaper after getting betrayed by his
student
the reaper was captured by the
government to run some experiments on
his body
experiments that would have created
anti-matter in the human cells
however after feeling he achieved the
peak of his new power and growing tired
from torture
the reaper goes on a rampage to escape
the facility he's held in
in front of him there are a dozen
foolish heavily armed men and a series
of tentacle booby traps which he breezes
out
of in that escape we witness for the
first time how goro sensei looks when he
goes completely mad
and why he's the most dangerous man on
earth luckily after the massacre his
heart moved when he saw his beloved ugly
between the rubles
then and there he decided to be the best
version of himself and bring the best
out of people by becoming the teacher
class
3e grew to love
what
when you get in a motorcycle accident
while you're in the middle of a gang war
the last thing you expect is to walk
away unharmed which was the case for
tetsuoshima as luck would have it
and not only did he walk out in one
piece but he also walked out upgraded
with some psychic powers which in turn
intrigued the interest of the japanese
government
taking him to a hospital testing
building where he was getting treated
for his injuries and getting monitored
after a series of hallucinations and the
espakids [ __ ] with him
tetsuya has enough and goes on the
hallway of death
first victims on the path of destruction
were a doctor and two guards
and after that soldiers started dying
left and right in the amazing display of
smoke animation
tetsuo escaping was truly one of the
best animated scenes i've ever seen
[Music]
is
[Music]
imagine being this cute and treated as
an experiment now that must be some next
level cruelty
if i remember right eerie's first
appearance happened while she was
escaping
overhaul who was using her special quirk
to make bullets
aries escape was going to be successful
after she came across young midoriya and
mini or might
clingy hard to the izuku hero costume
she had no plans to get back with
overhaul
however the successful escape was cut
short overhaul knew how to play it smart
by making izuku and mario follow him
into a dark alley
where the pure-hearted sweet eerie knew
what was going to happen so she
willingly went to overhaul side to get
back to the experimenting site just
because she didn't want the green wimp
getting hurt
however fast forward loads of events and
the heroes team up and go to rescue area
after finding their balls
and by god what an action spectacle that
was
[Music]
[Applause]
sixteen years later elfin lee did what
akira did but with more detached bodies
blood and nudity the title character
lucy's a special breed of human born
with a short pair of horns and invisible
telekinetic hands
that lands her as a victim of inhumane
scientific experimentation by the
government
however once circumstances present her
an opportunity to escape
lucy unleashes a torrent of bloodshed as
she escapes leaving arms on the floor
heads twisted detached bodies broken and
cut in half
with blood splatted all over the room
you get the idea don't you
here's a show i forgot all about until
we started making this video
arjun aka the cgi tokyo ghoul
featuring k the main man getting
captured by none other than the
government
to run some testing in the form of
torture and if you thought what garnicky
went through was hard
wait to see the hell this guy went
through we're talking drills to the head
knives to the heart cutting limbs and
not to mention casually killing him so
the scientists can have a tea break
all these had k on the verge of becoming
an edge lord with white hair
but he fought through the pain that
forced his black ghost out
unlike the expectations of the other
argents who turned him in
kaye didn't kill the people hunting him
making the plan that would have made kay
hate humans a failure but that didn't
stop sato to save him from the facility
when santos started killing helpless
surgeons left and right
our boy stood his ground and killed sato
changing the escape from the facility
mission to
survive from the fellow arjun mission ps
this is a
highly recommended show and don't let
the cgi scare you away
it's a good show and surprisingly the
cgi is decent
next we have the breakout of you ayumi
shinsuke and everybody else from
charlotte
the episode begins with a date that ends
when now and you go to a concert
where you start having flashbacks of his
past the past where you and his sister
ayumi were living together in a facility
where they monitor and experiment on
kids with powers the escape sequence
starts when ayumi gets taken to be
experimented on
and after forcing her collapse ability
to prematurely start
half of the facility gets destroyed
which in turn forces you to move fast
steal others powers to reach his big
brother shunsuke who has the power to
control time and in turn
free everyone in the building and his
sister before they dissect her
making this escape plan the most
calculated and least bloody out of the
punch
granted a lot of people must have died
when the building got destroyed
but that happened off-screen besides i'm
an advocate of the saying
pics or it didn't happen
guys
and finally we left one of the oldest
entries for last
ball aired back in 1989 it's an ova that
features an innocent young man who has a
parasite known as baal implanted in his
brain by an evil organization
the parasite makes him nearly immortal
and gives him the ability to transform
into a powerful beasty when he's in
trouble
we get introduced to the man immediately
from the start when he's getting
transported on a train while in a
medical coma in a capsule filled with
water
at the same time we get introduced to a
young psychic girl who's also being held
by the organization because of her
abilities
while trying to escape from the same
train the guy was held in she mistakenly
enters the room of the main man
affecting the pressure of the room
and consequently the water level in the
capsule waking the guy up which then
sets him free the breakout like the
previous escapes wasn't short on blood
but this show kicked it up a notch with
some animal cruelty so if you decide to
watch this 1989 show which isn't half
bad i mean the art style is quite nice
beware some scenes might be too
sensitive for some
and with that we've finished the video
we hope you enjoyed the video and have
got interested in seeing some of the
mentioned shows
if you know some good shows where
characters escape the experiments
then do share in the comments and share
this video with your friends
they might have some unknown anime
titles under their belt that they can
drop in the comments section
other than that make sure you like
subscribe turn on the notification
and we shall hopefully upload our next
one sooner